[Music]
there is now a woman
living in an rv after losing her life
savings in a crypto dating scheme oh no
wow we're right at the moral of the
story
she she got ripped off she got scammed
how much
a woman has lost 330
or 330.
390
and is now living in an rv after falling
for a crypto dating scam sounds like my
life
wow
how do you so what yeah how do you fall
for
how do you fall for that have you ever
been scammed in any any way shape or
form
um
no oh well i can understand why you
would say that then no you're the guy
who doesn't know he got scammed but he
got scammed yeah repeatedly maybe maybe
i get scammed all the time you're
fleeced you never ordered something on
ebay and then found out it was from
china and they just never sent it it's
like that always works out
found out it was from china but never
got it they do that [ __ ] where they'll
say the us company and then right when
the shipping goes it'll end up being
from like beijing and then it just never
never gets crazy i thought i was buying
a paddleboard on instagram because there
was an ad and i was like dude that's
sick man a paddleboard for like 30 bucks
hell yeah right
30 bucks 30 bucks and then like the way
that they did it it was so clever
because the the ad is just like a
[ __ ] dude using a paddle board right
and then after i bought it i was like
man you see the pictures again because i
can't believe i'm getting this for 30
bucks and i read the comments and
they're like scam it's just a paddle i
can't believe it
that's like all the people who are
buying xbox boxes remember that [ __ ]
oh yeah boxes yeah and i just bought it
and i just got a paddle
because i thought they were [ __ ]
giving me the whole scent it's a good
paddle because they kept showing the
board did you get the paddle no because
i moved so i went to my old other
battles
damn dude so you wouldn't have even
gotten the board because you were gonna
maybe you didn't get the board take your
calls
i said i wanna i want a refund and
they're like sorry we already shipped it
i'm like no you did it i bought this an
hour ago
you're like we're that good
sorry you shipped it so her name is
nicole hutchinson from tennessee she
inherited her mother's house after she
died and she split the 280 000 proceeds
with her dad melvin right the cash from
the sale was earmarked to help the 24
year old start a new life with her
family in california
in a bid to make friends after moving to
a new city hutchinson downloaded a
dating app and it was here she met and
befriended a guy
called hal
h-a-o
oh man it's like the tinder player
[ __ ] asian guy did this [ __ ]
yeah the two struck up a friendship it
was hal that was his first oh yeah maybe
it's hal yeah shallow hal no it's it's
detroit
how the two uh struck up a friendship
and she felt a connection to the man as
he claimed he was from the same chinese
town she had been adopted from
playing the hardship damn he did he did
his research because then tell me a
story right and then she's like oh i was
i was born here
no way
me dude and she's like oh we have so
many in common yeah
what's your birthday
me too
[Laughter]
that's good
that would be good if you also had the
same birthday that's too good
we're like
how much money you have me too
you know what we should go 50 50 on this
crypto thing
so that's where it gets there how told
hutchinson he invested money into
cryptocurrency and encouraged her to
give it a go as she'd never invested
cash before hutchinson was initially
skeptical but says howe was able to
reassure her that he understood the
market well
he told her to set up an account on the
legitimate crypto trading site
crypto.com but then sent her a new link
and told her to transfer money there
explaining that it was a cryptocurrency
exchange platform oh boy
hutchinson started small
but was encouraged to start investing
bigger amounts
she told cbs he's just he was just uh he
just kept saying things of like look at
this money that can help support your
family obviously that's what i wanted to
do and when her account started to show
profits hutchinson then suggested to dad
melvin
that he invests too
oh no within months their accounts
showed a balance of 1.2 million dollars
and they decided they wanted to cash out
how do you think
they showed the profit they're using
they're using a diff
different api feed into a fake website
so they can put whatever numbers they
want in there yeah absolutely within
months after their account showed the
balance of 1.2 million all right they
wanted to cash out but before they could
get their hands on the cash she was told
she'd need to pay a tax bill of 380 000
it was then that she had learned that
all the investments she made weren't
real and that all their money had gone
directly to their scammers
the eye because they're creating a new
crypto task force
really there's so much [ __ ] going on
crypto task force this is her just i
like how they caught her crying dang
the emotional storytelling that's a good
photo yeah it's a a photo i cry
you gotta you gotta have the emotion as
part of the narrative otherwise people
don't learn their lessons that's true
because a part of me just went damn you
got suckered if only you're a part of
crypto corner with steve
i mean uh we've crushed this
[ __ ] market i gotta say
that's pretty crazy you googled the
first time i wore a jake a hat a tear
hat on jk and then remember that well i
had to buy that hat so i probably took
two weeks so i bought that hat in
february of 2021
and here we are today so just google the
price back then with tara luna february
2021 and google price today what was the
price back that's been incredible uh i
was buying it five bucks
damn
what is that i know it just i mean it
just hit
95.96 yesterday it it all-time high was
102 like
and it went back down to like 58 60. we
beat the entire [ __ ] market that's
the beauty
she should have listened she should have
listened to steve but steve's a scam
artist don't remember that that's right
i mean you could literally google when i
wore the hat
and then you see how erect everybody got
can people google it like when did steve
wear tara and you should be able to go
with that well you can you can go to
jk's video history just go find the
[ __ ] hat dude yeah [ __ ] yeah i
should have listened to steve
hutchinson and her dad are now living in
an rv but have decided to share their
story as a warning to others she said i
just hope others don't have to fall for
it so if me sharing this story helps
that i don't like how they i don't like
how they talk about now we live in an rv
like it's a bad thing
countries
can be cool our views are free
no this is california that's california
oh [ __ ] they're not [ __ ] that's not
that big of a deal dude
rvs in california they're still like
over a hundred grand they're pretty
sweet yeah you if you have an rv if it's
new you're rich [ __ ] who dude yeah
i mean if you're gonna live in an rv
anywhere at least a state where there's
nothing that's gonna [ __ ] with you does
it say what crypto that he says that she
was getting or what kind of rvs
it's the [ __ ] aluminum ones
i don't know all airstreams are sick
they aren't cool right dude rvs
i would love to live in an rv
everyone's totally will one day
if i'm going i'm going down this
trajectory i'm laughing because this is
my life but i think it's amazing she
thinks it's a tragedy
well i i think i think that they got a
house
and then they like
took the money yeah and then put it in a
crypto and then they got turned into an
rv so joe where did you where'd you go
wrong man where'd you where'd you i
cashed out early yeah
you know
um are you are you sure yeah um
um now i'm homeless okay for a month i
used to live in a garage even went even
more down in the dumps
so uh yeah i'm kind of struggling and um
don't know what to do with my life um
okay yeah all right so we won't be
seeing any any news from you in the
future about any cool stuff going on any
cool purchases nothing
no i mean like this is debt probably
right i got a new truck yeah but
you got a new truck again
uh yeah no yeah if joe gets a house dead
dead
it's not cause i own it no take it out
dude that [ __ ] is sick that better not
be the one they live in their shoes i
don't think it's the one they live in
that looks like the kill bill one of the
[ __ ] joshua tree airbnb
but that's that's sick as [ __ ] i'd want
one of those
one of these he wants to put in his
[ __ ] backyard
a lot of people are getting [ __ ] so
hard on like just just the crypto space
though because um
you know there's like a lot of people
like in this situation where they're
like oh i know a friend who's like
really successful in crypto like they
can help you out you think that's a scam
dude
a lot of the times yeah it depends right
what's your plan i always want to know
what your plan is right okay so you want
to get into crypto cool what are you
doing it for do you have a plan like do
you do you have a goal just want to be
rich right right what's the point
because like for example i was buying a
coin called v chain when it was like a
couple cents it ran up like 22 cents i
sold it back then me and my crypto
corner crew sold it back then right and
so you could see me wearing a hat and
shirt then but i was like i'm not in
this for long there's a play money move
i'm getting the [ __ ] out and then i'm
able to stack even more luna that way
and if you're able to make moves like
with a plan then you can
get in and out of things
more more i would argue that 90 plus
percent of retail investors that get
into those things are first hearing
about the euphoria and the glory of just
being like yo i made this much money and
so people want to just make the money
without doing the research which is like
it's it's a age-old testament to just
like i don't even want to call it greed
you know what i mean because it's oh
it's greed bro it's so innocent
yeah you know what i'm saying though
like well yeah that's true because i
think there's a difference like when
you're like already in it and then
you've gotten a taste of it and then
you're like all right well uh my plan
was to catch up once it got here but
uh it's so good now i'm gonna hold on to
that that's why we don't have a plan
yeah that's a different kind of greed
you know like abandoning your plan and
just wanting more when you already got
some but i feel like a lot of people who
are just like getting introduced to it
it's almost more innocent than greed
which is why they have to sometimes
endure scams in order to like almost pay
their tuition fees to learn of like the
power of that space because you know 300
grand is a big this this specific way of
getting scammers like almost not even a
crypto based thing it's just someone
didn't know anything about anything and
you didn't do money just trusting
someone this is harder actually because
like i've told steve i've been like
scammed before too where it's like you
just think you're like participating in
a protocol that like has a lucrative
reward you know what i mean and then
you're just doing stuff but that's your
wallet to it that's what you think yeah
you link your like you put your seed
phrase right you know what i mean that's
like you thinking you're even doing
research and that [ __ ] is like pretty
engineered like the way that they set it
up it like speaks the language to get
you this is even harder because this is
like a human being you know what i mean
manipulating another human that's what's
weird is that it could have been
anything like this person probably would
have been a victim of stocks any kind of
real estate yeah just like any
investment the lack of not having
another peer to be like hey can you look
at this and tell me if this is on the
level like that obviously didn't happen
i think that's the thing trusting up
here yeah i think yeah but that's what i
think that's where the second third
party like when someone presents you
something you go that's cool let me look
into this and you're supposed to read up
on it and you're supposed to ask other
people and cross-reference yeah just
like because like if you only have one
source like in her case i guarantee you
this person was the only [ __ ]
that was her gateway to crypto and this
person that's how you get scammed is and
also they were like sort of in a
relationship yeah yeah so like it was
probably so easy for her to be like yeah
my boyfriend told me this yeah but then
it's a boyfriend that was she never met
right so she was basically not only
getting catfished
she was also being scammed she was
that's a double whammy
damn and was it even his real mark
yeah dude was it even his real dick
picture
yeah what kind of dick pic do you send
is that an article
yes it's an honor you want me to pull it
up because this goes straight to patreon
if i do that because i i feel like
really bad because people out there are
easily like trusting of someone that
they like and then people that you like
doesn't necessarily mean like they're
going to be great
or like you could trust them 100 you got
to test them and i think that's really
important
[Music]